taylor heinecke may be something that
washington has found as a candidate for
their quarterback in 2021 and maybe
beyond let's talk about
some of the losers from wild card
weekend hey it's football there's
winners and there's losers and even
though washington lost we expected them
to lose they may have found something
what did you see
from uh heineken chris and do you think
that that he has a fair shot at at
taking that job next year should he get
a fair shot at i don't know if i could
say that i don't know if i say you know
it was an unbelievable performance it
really was and i'm not trying to take
anything away but we have seen nothing
that has been like that
you know as far as preseason football i
know he got to play in carolina a little
bit you know did well at the end of the
carolina panthers game a few weeks ago
as well you know but we had never seen a
performance like that where you just go
oh
okay i mean that that's it we got to
sign him and he's got to be the starting
quarterback
so i think he certainly earned the right
to go back there and be the backup
quarterback compete that compete for
that and maybe even be a backup
quarterback somewhere else but i don't
think just off of one performance you
can just go we found our guy and now
we're going to go with that
i don't think that will go over with the
fan base and you know again i think i
would need more evidence and a few more
games to see a guy before i anoint him
that so yeah they still have to address
the quarterback situation there's no
doubt but man washington
i'm excited about washington
awesome defensive line good offensive
line antonio gibson terry mclaurin you
know logan thomas a tight end there's a
lot of things to like about their team
they're not far off you know they get a
quarterback and you know a player here
and a player there and i'd say watch out
for washington in 2021.
you know the thing about taylor heinecke
that i'd be concerned about i feel like
he emptied the tank in an effort to
audition for the job taking some
physical risks getting himself banged up
having to go to the locker room you know
it may not be sustainable
right full speed sprint for a whole game
he did it for one game trying to secure
his future trying to help the team
advance that's not a week in and week
out answer at the quarterback position
and you know there's been some rumors
linking cam newton to washington because
of the ron rivera connection nine years
together in carolina i'm not sure that
that works for either guy i think that
they both may need to go their own way
but obviously the quarterback position
needs to get solved in washington and
once they solve it once they get
somebody they feel good about alex smith
do make more than 18 million next year
he's not sure he's going to play they're
surely not going to want to pay him that
that to me is the big question for them
what's their strategy sign a free agent
and it seems like every year now there
will be free agent quarterbacks where
for years there were none yeah every
year there's going to be options or you
draft a guy or you try to trade for a
guy but that's going to be the key what
does ron rivera and scott turner want
what do they envision their quarterback
being because
with the defense and the weapons
this could be a team right
that doesn't just become
you know a seven and nine division
champion on a regular basis they could
be the team that takes over the nfc i i
yeah i don't doubt that i really don't
you know the the hard work is done as
you've said you know they got guys to
win battles up front
they got some young you know talented
guys you know the team is really you
know in a pretty good spot all together
and you know as far as the cam newton
conversation you're right i hear that a
lot over the last few weeks
i don't think that makes any sense for
the washington football team you know
they got a
a younger team that is growing and has a
chance to go in an upward direction i
don't know if you want to bring a guy in
who's towards the end and where you
might be having this same conversation
you know a year or two from now again
going okay now who are we going to bring
in after cam newton and also yes a guy
like cam newton we know he's a different
presence a different guy in the locker
room all together sometimes you know
you you don't want that kind of guy with
a young impressionable team that's kind
of growing so i don't think that makes
sense necessarily and i would expect
them to exhaust other avenues other than
cam newton and free agency or the draft
yeah everybody wants that answer for
five or ten years if they can find it
and i think that's job number one not a
not a band-aid but a foundation for the
future of the franchise the bears
thought they had their foundation in
mitchell trubisky who was the second
overall pick after they traded up in the
2017 draft his contract now expired
technically not expired until march 17
at 4 pm eastern when he can sign with
anyone unless he re-signs with the bears
here's trubisky in the aftermath of
sunday's 21-9 loss to the saints on
whether or not he can be the answer for
the bears moving forward
mitch do you want to be back here next
year
yeah i think um
i think i could definitely see myself
back here next year obviously a lot of
that's
out of my control um
but it just
it feels like home and it feels like we
have unfinished business
um
and right now i'm really just
bummed about how the season being over
and how the game went so a lot of
emotions going on right now but um i
could see
i could see that but
we'll see there's a there's a lot of
things that gotta happen and a lot of
decisions that got to be made and
it's out of my control but i could see
that
it doesn't sound very convincing as he
says it you know that's the difference
between the words on paper and seeing
the words delivered i think he's just
saying what he has to say i could see it
yeah i could see it but i'd like to not
see it i'd like to see something new i
get the impression from trubisky that's
what he's looking for and the other side
of it too is what do the bears want are
they going to re-up mitchell trubisky
under these circumstances they didn't
use the fifth year option he's going to
be a free agent the franchise tag based
upon the performance we saw in the post
season highly unlikely
and you know we still don't know what
the bears are going to do by way of
their gm and their head coach there's
speculation in chicago that gm ryan pace
could be in danger i don't like the idea
of firing the gm and matching the gm
with the coach who's already been there
matt and aggies won uh enough to get to
the playoffs twice in his first three
seasons and just got there this year
yeah they were eight and eight but they
still got there i i i think you keep
both or you keep neither yeah and if you
keep neither finally they've got to have
the conversation about whether or not
team president ted phillips needs to go
so maybe just keep all three and do it
again but quarterback is going to be key
chris i i you know trubisky i'd be
surprised if he's back
they got to get somebody who can run the
offense the way that matt neggie wants
to run it period if matt maggie's not
going to completely and totally overhaul
the offense although we saw some of that
this year i think he'd rather run his
offense he needs to find someone who can
run his offense all right but you know
that's limited people you know i don't
what's he want to run kansas city and
well find me patrick mahomes and then
fine let's go okay oh that's right
that's kind of hard they had a shot at
it i know yeah right i know if you
haven't heard so the first thing is i i
mean i am more of along your lines you
know chicago's closer to the top than
the bottom i don't look at this as like
a tear down job yeah i know like you
know the gm ryan pace has had a few
mistakes here and there but overall that
bear's roster is pretty damn good it's
not perfect matineeky i think i could
say the same thing you know yeah there's
been some mistakes and certainly you
know the offense is underwhelming but
overall it's been pretty damn good i
mean 12 and four what was it uh in 2019
eight and eight right didn't make the
playoffs this year it's eight and eight
they got in the playoffs and you know
still continued to fight and fought
through a lot of diversity he did show
the ability to adjust
i think that was key there you know as
far as the mitchell trubisky thing is
i would just say to chicago and go
well
like show me a better option to replace
him okay if you think you can get matt
stafford or something like that then
fine okay see you later mitchell
trubisky but if it's gonna be another
like
we're gonna bring in some nick foles not
really a starter in the nfl backup guy
then i would go that's just stupid stop
wasting your time give it to mitchell
trubisky there's not gonna be like
nobody's gonna pay mr trubisky franchise
money like you're saying or a big
contract they should be able to sign him
to a one or two year deal at a very
manageable number and work with that and
just fix the roster a little bit and if
matt and aggie's willing to go all in on
this style offense or adjusting to the
players he has then damn they could be
better than they are that they were this
year and right back in the thick of
things so i'm in the favor of keeping
things the way they are there in chicago
and the worst thing that could happen
for the bears would be
to see trubisky go somewhere else and
have him become a star
somewhere else
that would just be the ultimate bag of
salt on the wound from taking trubisky
over
deshawn watson and patrick mahomes if
you end up having to hear about trubisky
being great somewhere else and you know
if there's
a coach that that looks at the skill set
and says i can get the most out of this
guy not quite make him into a josh allen
but like a josh allen you know you have
that mobility you've got the size if you
use it the right way if you use it smart
and you develop as a passer and you have
some good weapons around you
it's salvageable and maybe that's what
the bears need to do come up with some
sort of a short-term bridge option to
keep trubisky around unless they have a
better uh a better opportunity yeah to
upgrade but that's the key you gotta you
gotta look at what you have
versus what you may have and even though
there are more quarterbacks available
than ever before there still aren't
great quarterbacks just hanging around
waiting for someone to say hey come join
our team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports